but you've been married to Sophia for
for two years now yeah a little over two
years did you know that she was the one
like when did you know that like right
away she was in New Orleans shooting
this movie I was on a press tour I was
flying back and forth to to date her she
had just gotten out of this long
relationship so the second time I went
to go see her like People
magazine had put me on the cover of the
The Bachelor issue so I I grabbed it off
the shelf and I threw in my bag and I
went to go see her and we got to talking
and I said look I said I know you just
got out of this long-term relationship
and if you need to be single then I
understand I said but before you
[Music]
answer I reached through my bag and I
put down the magazine and I
said Numero Uno and so she she was
flipping by my interview and I said what
are you doing she said I'm seeing who
else is on the
list that's what he knew you're the one
for me the one for me yeah absolutely